1 même si vous me torturer je ne
donnerai pas ma source que le rapt est
une autre la semaine prochaine et oui
oui mais d'abord je voulais diffuser un
magnéto sur plusieurs chroniqueurs man
plusieurs en même temps vous allez
comprendre pourquoi un sur ces plusieurs
vous allez comprendre habitude on se
concentre sur un chroniqueur mais là en
fait je me suis baladée dans les
coulisses cette semaine est en fait vos
amis chroniqueur cyril ont des délires
parfois très bizarre pendant que lui
apprendre à prendre ou à laisser ça
pendant que vous êtes dans à prendre ou
à laisser et pas que mes rôles regardez
là je suis tombé il est temps voulait se
mettre dans la peau de thé au lavabo
c'est celui qui fait chaque fois la ta
c'était très très très gênant regarde je
suis ton gros
[Musique]
on a d'autres choses moins chère et la
donation
c'est magnifique a trouvé mon style
vous êtes vous avez pu vous avez pris le
même chemin ça va énormément c'est
difficile ça mouille énormément et ça
lui va très bien qu un playboy est
énormément succès grâce à m
effectivement maintenant je prends soin
à des non non non mais ça sert les gens
à les meufs adore ça les recharges la
combi ça donne des ombres et des lois la
marche arrêt elle oui bien sûr là par
contre on y voit beaucoup moins les oies
du slip on arrêté pour un fait du sert
et de la décote non il nous arrivait
coque n'ont pas eu besoin d'écoles
d'accord